just days after ryan lochte and three
other US Olympic swimmers claimed they
were robbed at gunpoint by men posing as
police officers authorities in Rio are
now investigating the validity of the
incident the 12-time Olympic medalist is
now back home in the US on Wednesday
NBC's Matt Lauer spoke with him by phone
he said nobody at the time he was
talking to anybody in law enforcement
said hey it would be a great idea if you
stick around Rio while the investigation
unfolds we might want to talk to you
Lauer continued explaining a lot D
expressed he was never doubted by Rio
officials during questioning in fact
Lochte claims they even congratulated
him on his performance at the games
however Lauer added that Lochte story
did change slightly when he recounted
what happened during the alleged robbery
one thing he did not say this time he
said that's when the guy took the gun
put it to his forehead and cocked it
when he talked to me tonight he said
that's when the guy pointed the gun in
my direction and cocked it as for
speculation Lochte and the other
swimmers fabricated the story the 32
year old swimmer maintained to lower
that simply not the case he strongly
denied that said it's absolutely not the
case I wouldn't make up a story like
this nor with the others as a matter of
fact we all feel it makes us look bad
we're victims in this and we're happy
that we're safe